.
>> AND WE ARE BACK WITH SOME
BREAKING NEWS JUST INTO CNN VERY
SAD NEWS.
ACTOR MATTHEW PERRY HAS DIED AT
THE AGE OF 54.
THE LOS ANGELES TIMES QUOTING
LAW ENFORCEMENT FORCES IS
REPORTING THE FRIENDS STAR WAS
FOUND DEAD IN A HOT TUB TODAY IN
HIS LOS ANGELES HOME.
THE L.A. TIMES SAID SOURCES
SPOKE ON THE CONDITION OF
ANONYMITY.
THERE WAS NO SIGNS OF FOUL PLAY.
PERRY IS BEST KNOWN FOR HIS ROLE
OF CHANDLER, AND FRIENDS.
PERRY APPEARED IN EVERY EPISODE
OF FRIENDS, HIS BATTLE WITH
ALCOHOL AND DRUGS, SPECIFICALLY
PAINKILLERS WAS WELL-KNOWN.
HIS AUTOBIOGRAPHY.
HE WENT TO REHAB MORE THAN 60
TIMES.
KAMALA WHAT MORE DO WE KNOW
ABOUT MATTHEW PERRY'S DEATH?
>> PAM VERY FEW DETAILS HERE BUT
AS YOU MENTIONED THE L.A. TIMES
SAYS THIS WAS AN PARENT DROWNING
ACCIDENT AT HIS L.A. HOME,
HATCHED TODAY.
WE HAVE REACHED OUT TO MATTHEW
PERRY'S TEAM WE ALSO REACHED OUT
TO THE L.A.P.D, THEY HAVE NOT
GOTTEN BACK TO US.
BUT THE L.A. TIMES SAYING THERE
IS NO APPARENT FOUL PLAY IN THIS
INCIDENT.
UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE WAITING TO
GET THAT CONFIRMATION FROM
L.A.P.D. AND FROM MATTHEW
PERRY'S TEAM THERE.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS OBVIOUSLY
EXTREMELY HEARTBREAKING FOR THE
HOLLYWOOD COMMUNITY AND REALLY
FOR THE WORLD, THAT WATCHED
FRIENDS.
THIS WAS SUCH A GREAT SHOW.
MATTHEW PERRY WAS YOU OBVIOUSLY
CHANDLER BANG, HE MADE SO MANY
OF US LAUGH FOR SO MANY SEASONS,
SO BE EPISODES, JUST WATCHING
THE REUNION EPISODE, IT WAS NICE
TO SEE THE WHOLE TEAM, TO SEE
THE GANG THERE.
UNFORTUNATELY, THIS IS THE NEWS
THAT WE'RE GETTING TODAY.
WE'LL HAVE TO WAIT FOR THAT
CONFIRMATION.
AND AS YOU MENTIONED, MATTHEW
PERRY WAS VERY OPENED OR OPEN
ABOUT HIS STRUGGLES WITH
ADDICTION.
AND SO AS OF NOW, THE L.A. TIMES
IS ALSO SAYING NO FOUL PLAY
SUSPECTED BUT AGAIN WE HAVE TO
WAIT FOR A LOT OF THOSE DETAILS,
PAM.
>> WE DO AND SO MANY OF US KNOW
HIM FROM FRIENDS AND THEN HE
REALLY REEMERGED IN A BIG WAY
WHEN HIS AUTOBIOGRAPHY WOULD
SAY, WENT TO REHAB MANY TIMES
AND THAT HE WAS FINALLY ABLE TO
BREAK THE CYCLE OF ADDICTION.
TELL US MORE ABOUT WHAT WE KNOW
ABOUT MATTHEWY FROM HIS MEMOIR,
THOSE INTERVIEWS HE DID AS WE
LEARN OF HIS UNTIMELY DEATH AT
THE AGE OF 54 ACCORDING TO THE
L.A. TIMES, BEING FOUND IN A HOT
TUB DEAD.
AGAIN LEARNING MORE
CIRCUMSTANCES SURROUNDING HIS
DEATH WAITING FOR POLICE TO
PROVIDE MORE DETAILS.
BUT TELL US A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT HIS BACKGROUND IF YOU
WOULD KAMALA.
>> YES -- CAMILA.
>> YOU MENTIONED THE INTERVIEW,
HE DID A LOT OF INTERVIEWS AS HE
WAS PROMOTING HIS BOOK AND HE
WAS WILLING TO SPEAK ABOUT
EVERYTHING THAT HAPPENED TO HIM.
HE WOULD GET EXTREMELY EMOTIONAL
AS HE TALKED ABOUT HIS STRUGGLES
AND GOING IN AND OUT OF REHAB
AND AS YOU MENTIONED.
WHAT HE WENT THROUGH EVEN AS HE
WAS FILMING FRIENDS BECAUSE THIS
WAS OF COURSE SORT OF THE
BIGGEST SHOW OF HIS CAREER BUT
HE SPOKE ABOUT GOING THROUGH
THOSE STRUGGLES EVEN THROUGH THE
TAPING OF FRIENDS AND GOING
THROUGH THESE EPISODES AND STILL
SHOWING UP, RIGHT?
AND STILL MAKING US LAUGH.
AND STILL JUST MAKING EVERYBODY
HAPPY.
AND IT WAS JUST SUCH A GOOD
SHOW, RIGHT?
AND HE BROUGHT SUCH A FUN ASPECT
TO THE SHOW WITH HIS JOKES, WITH
HIS PERSONALITY.
SO IT WAS INTERESTING TO SEE
BOTH SIDES, RIGHT?
THE PERSON THAT HE PLAYED ON
FRIENDS BUT ALSO THE PERSON THAT
WAS STRUGGLING WITH THIS
ADDICTION BEHIND CLOSED DOORS.
AND SO I THINK ANYBODY THAT WAS
AROUND IN THE 90s OR THAT GREW
UP IN THE 90s WATCHED CHANDLER
BANG AND WAS EXCITED TO SEE HIM
SORT OF OVERCOME THAT ADDICTION.
AGAIN WE HAVE TO WAIT TO CONFIRM
THE FOUL PLAY.
THAT'S WHAT THE L.A. TIMES IS
SAYING THAT RIGHT NOW THAT IS
NOT THE CASE.
SO WE'LL JUST HAVE TO WAIT ON
THOSE DETAILS FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
BUT IT IS A LONG CAREER AND OF
COURSE, ONE THAT'S VERY
WELL-KNOWN FOR HIS ROLE IN
FRIENDS.
>> YES, YOU KNOW, THE FRIENDS
WAS HIS BIGGEST CLAIM TO PAYMENT
BUT HE STARRED AND GUEST STARRED
IN COUNTLESS OTHER SHOWS, BOYS
WILL BE BOYS, CHARLES IN CHARGE,
THE WEST WING SCRUBS, STEWED YES
66, THE ODD COUPLE AND MANY
MORS.
HE RECENTLY RESURFACED IN THE
FRIENDS REUNION THAT I KNOW A
LOT OF FRIENDS FANS WERE EAGERLY
AWAITING AND WATCHING.
>> YES AND ON SOCIAL MEDIA THERE
WAS A LOT OF TALK ABOUT THE
REUNION AND HOW HE LOOKED AND
THE WAY THAT HE SPOKE DURING THE
REUNION.
THERE WERE A LOT OF QUESTIONS
ABOUT WHAT HE WAS GOING THROUGH.
BUT HE CAME OUT AND SAID LOOK
I'M OKAY I'M IN A GOOD PLACE.
SO IT IS UNCLEAR EXACTLY HOW HE
WAS AT THE MOMENT OR JUST
RECENTLY.
YOU KNOW LAST WE HEARD, HE DID
SPEAK OUT SAYING THAT HE WAS
FINE.
BUT WE HAVE TO WAIT TO PROBABLY
HEAR FROM HIS TEAM TO REALLY
FIGURE OUT WHAT HE WAS GOING
THROUGH, IF HE WAS GOING THROUGH
ANYTHING AT THE MOMENT, OR AS
THE L.A. TIMES WAS SAYING THIS
APPEARS TO HAVE BEEN AN
ACCIDENT.
>> YES NO FOUL PLAY ACCORDING TO
THE L.A. TIMES AND AGAIN HE
SPOKE JUST LAST YEAR I BELIEVE
IT WAS ABOUT THE FACT THAT HE
HAD STRUGGLED WITH ADDICTION
THAT HE HAD BROKEN THAT CYCLE OF
ADDICTION THROUGH A LOT OF HARD
WORK OVER MANY YEARS.
AND, YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU LOOK AT
HIS CHARACTER IN FRIENDS,
CHANDLER, IT WAS SUCH A FAN
FAVORITE, RIGHT?
I MEAN, YOU KNOW, AND MAYBE FOR
THE YOUNGER GENERATION WHO
DIDN'T WATCH FRIENDS, PEOPLE
LOVED THAT SHOW BUT THEY ALSO
LOVED HIS CHARACTER.
HE MADE SUCH AN IMPRESSION ON
PEOPLE.
I THINK THAT WAS ALSO WHY WHEN
HE CAME OUT WITH HIS MEMOIR, IT
WAS A STRUGGLE FOR PEOPLE WHEN
HE HAD THESE ISSUES.
HE WAS SO BELOVED.
>> YES, WE FELL IN LOVE WITH
CHANDLER RIGHT AND HE MADE US
FALL IN LOVE WITH CHANDLER AND
MONICA.
IT WAS FUN TO WATCH HIM BE
AROUND THE GROUP BECAUSE HE
BROUGHT SO MUCH JOY AS CHANDLER,
RIGHT AND HE ALWAYS HAD A GOOD
LINE OR SOMETHING IN THE WAY
THAT HE SPOKE OR HIS GESTURES
THAT MADE US LAUGH.
AND SO REALLY, THROUGHOUT THE
90s WE ALL FELL IN LOVE WITH
CHANDLER BING AND HE MADE US
WANT TO WATCH FRIENDS.
IT WAS ALL OF THEM T